>> Laura: JOINING ME NOW,
KELLYANNE CONWAY, I WANT YOU TO
RESPOND TO TONIGHT'S
BREAKING NEWS THAT
SPEAKER PELOSI WILL NOT COMMIT
TO SENDING THE ARTICLES OF
IMPEACHMENT THAT THEY WERE SO
SET ON SENDING.
>> IF THIS IS BEEN SO FUN, WHY
DID THE BUSINESS OF THE PEOPLE
WHEN YOUR DAY JOB IS
REPRESENTATIVE AND YOU ARE NOT
REPRESENTING THE WILL OF THE
PEOPLE.
THE POLES HAVE GONE AGAINST A
PROTRACTED IMPEACHMENT
PROCEEDING IN THE HOUSE.
I THINK THAT THE MEANDERING
PROCESS ACTUALLY HURT THEM.
THE SUBSTANCE IS NEVER ON THEIR
SIDE, BUT THE WAY THEY TRIED TO
PRESENT IT NEVER REALLY CAPTURED
THE PUBLIC AND MADE IT STICKY
ENOUGH TO STICK AROUND AND
FOLLOW THE PROCEDURES SO I THINK
THE SENATE TRIAL WOULD BE A MORE
FAMILIAR AND MORE FAIR PROCESS
BUT OF COURSE SHE WANTS TO WAIT
BECAUSE SHE WILL NEVER MOLLIFY
ALL OF THE HATERS AND DETRACTOR
DETRACTORS.
>> Laura: DOESN'T SHE WANT TO
DENY HIM AN ACQUITTAL?
SPEAKER SHE WANTS TO GO ON AND
ON SO SHE CAN GATHER MORE
EVIDENCE.
FIRST THEY WERE RUSHING THROUGH
IT, THE CLOCK IN THE CALENDAR,
NOW THEY WANT TO WAIT AND YOU
KNOW WHO IS PROBABLY HOPPING
MAD?
THE 2020 DEMOCRATIC PRESIDENTIAL
FIELD.
THEY HAVE A DEBATE SCHEDULED
TOMORROW NIGHT.
DOES ANYBODY CARE CUSTOMER THEY
CAN'T GET A WORD IN EDGE WISE.
>> Laura: UNTIL YOU REMINDED
ME OF THAT TODAY, DID YOU GUYS
EVEN REMEMBER THERE WAS A
DEMOCRATIC DEBATE?
THANK YOU FOR REMINDING ME.
>> IT DOESN'T MATTER, THIS IS
THE MODERN DEMOCRATIC PARTY AND
THEIR LIST HAS BEEN A COUPLE OF
PEOPLE, RUSSIA, RECOUNTS,
OBSTRUCTION, IMPEACHMENT, OUR
LATEST IS A TRADE DEAL, A
TRIFECTA TRADE DEAL, A BOOMING
ECONOMY, SMASHING RECORDS EVERY
DAY, DEREGULATION.
>> Laura: HOW MANY MORE DID WE
GET TODAY?
>> WE WILL JUST PACKAGE THEM
TOGETHER NOW, WE CAN'T DO ONE AT
A TIME, THEY WILL BE CLOSE TO
200 BEFORE WE KNOW IT.
TRUMP JUDGES, THE NINTH CIRCUIT.
>> Laura: WHEN I WAS A CLERK
ON THE COURT I NEVER THOUGHT IT
WOULD HAVE A NINTH CIRCUIT COURT
OF APPEALS THAT WAS ACTUALLY
DOMINATING.
>> AND TODAY, GOT UP PRETTY
FAVORABLE RULE ON TEXAS.
OBAMACARE.
BUT IT PUT A STAKE THROUGH THE
HEART OF OBAMACARE.
>> Laura: CONGRESSMAN LUJAN
TODAY MADE THIS CLAIM ON THE
HOUSE FLOOR, AND I KID YOU NOT.
WATCH.
>> NO ONE CAME TO CONGRESS TO
IMPEACH A PRESIDENT BUT THIS
MOMENT HAS FOUND US.
>> [LAUGHS]
I'M SORRY, IF I GOT ONE MORE
LECTURE ABOUT TOM KANE AND THE
FOUNDING FATHERS, YOU WOULD
THINK HE WOULD SHOW UP IN MUTTON
CHOPS.
THEY WERE SO RIDICULOUS SO
RIDICULOUS.
>> Laura: [LAUGHS]
SPARK NOTES VERSION OF AMERICAN
HISTORY.
>> THESE ARE PEOPLE WHO CAN'T
EVEN GET TO THE SECOND
AMENDMENT, LET ALONE FOLLOW IT,
AND ALL OF A SUDDEN THEIR
CONSTITUTIONAL EXPERTS.
DO YOU KNOW WHY?
THEY COULDN'T HOLD FORTH IN THE
TWO, THREE, 4 MINUTES THEY HAD
ON THE FACTS.
IF THEY HAD GREAT FACTS AND
EVIDENCE ON THEIR SIDE.
IF THEY TRULY HAD TREASON,
BRIBERY, EXTORTION, QUID PRO
QUO, COLLUSION, THEY COULDN'T
EVEN SLIDE THE MUELLER FINDINGS
IN THERE, SO THEY SPENT THEIR
TIME TALKING ABOUT THE FOUNDERS
AND THE CONSTITUTION.
I DON'T NEED TO BE LECTURED BY
THE CONSTITUTION.
>> Laura: LINDSEY GRAHAM SAID
THEY DIDN'T WANT TO CALL
WITNESSES TO THE SENATE, SO, YOU
KNOW WHAT I'M SAYING?
WHAT IS NANCY REALLY THINKING
HERE?
I'M STILL GOING BACK TO THIS NOT
SENDING THE ARTICLES TO THE
SENATE BECAUSE SHE IS GOING TO
USE THIS TO CHAR McCONNELL AND
SAY, IT'S ALL COLLUSION BETWEEN
THE SENATE REPUBLICANS, AND
TRUMP AND THEY ARE TRYING TO
KEEP THE TRUTH FROM YOU AND WE
WANT DOCUMENTS.
>> THEY CAN'T GET A FAIR TRIAL
BECAUSE YOU ALREADY HAVE
LINDSEY GRAHAM SAYING, WE ARE
ALREADY LOOKING AT THIS, WE'VE
ALREADY TALKED TO THE
WHITE HOUSE ABOUT THE TIMING.
BUT GUESS WHAT?
YOU KNOW WHO IS NOT IMPARTIAL?
ALL THESE DEMOCRATIC SENATORS
RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT WHO HAVE
ALREADY TOLD YOU THEY WANT TO
IMPEACH THE PRESIDENT.
KAMALA HARRIS IS NO LONGER
RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT BUT IS
STILL IN THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE.
CORY BOOKER, AMY KLOBUCHAR.
THEY ARE COMPLETELY PARTIAL.
BUT I THINK TODAY ALSO, IT
SHOWED WHAT HAPPENS WHEN PEOPLE
PUSH THE ENVELOPE TOO FAR, AND
PEOPLE WILL REMEMBER THIS IN
2020.
JUST LOOK AT DREW, HE'S GOT A
VERY BRIGHT FUTURE.
>> Laura: HE'S GOT A YEAR TO
GO.
A BIG FAT ON THE BUS THAT
CONSERVATIVES AREN'T THRILLED
ABOUT.
I'M NOT.
WE'VE GOT A LOT OF SPENDING
CUTTING TO DO.